today i'm going to be speaking with
daniel levitan who's a psychologist
neuroscientist author and professor
emeritus at mcgill university some of
his books include a field guide to lies
critical thinking with statistics and
the scientific method and also
weaponized lies how to think critically
in the post-truth era it's really great
having you on i appreciate it
thank you for having me david
so i mean where to start where to start
uh you know i i think maybe one place
that would be interesting would be for
context you know we we've recently been
doing a lot of thinking about
how to best engage in conversations with
people who might have different opinions
but also importantly
who maybe don't have a factual
foundation or basis on which we can have
those conversations or people who can't
tell the difference between news
reporting
and conspiracy articles that might be
shared on facebook as just general
examples one approach
is to
speak to these folks with like a
socratic type method of questioning
gently probing
how did you come to this conclusion how
do you determine if a news source is
trustworthy it's a it's a very long
process admittedly which sometimes is
effective at changing minds and
sometimes is not
where maybe we would start with you is
can you talk a little bit about whether
you believe that that's an ideal
framework for some of these
conversations or whether there might be
better or at least different approaches
to pair with that
i agree with you that we've got a
problem and the reason that
we are so divided as a country is we're
not using the same facts to come to
any any conclusion if at least we have
the same facts we may differ about how
we want to proceed from there
but without that it's bedlam
and uh i'm inspired here by the work of
lee mcintyre a philosopher who's done a
lot of work on this and i i'm with you
and with lee
uh
you can't
reason somebody out of a position
they didn't reason themselves into in
the first place
all you can do is listen uh
understand
and make under try to understand where
they're coming from
uh
allow them not to feel judged by you
uh and then as you say
uh ask questions about how they came to
believe what they believed and whether
they think uh you know step by step
is this a reliable source is there
another way to look at it and as as uh
as mcintyre says and as you said it's a
very long and arduous process but
it's all we got for now there's no
shortcuts in in other words we've
interviewed lee by the way on the
program and it was it was fascinating in
your work overall over the years
you've gone to the micro level of how
graphs are used to deceive and to lie
and you've also talked much more macro
sort of the way that that we just
started
today for 2022 where it's rapid-fire
social media sharing of fake articles
and it's truncated y-axis when you look
at an unemployment rate or stock market
numbers i mean it's sort of like an all
of the above thing can we go a little
narrower and specific about what you see
as some of the most commonly used tools
of deception
yes thank you uh
and we are currently doing some research
on this and there may be some quicker
ways to move the needle a little bit
that we can get to later
distorting graphs
is a big thing as you mentioned a
truncated y-axis where
you know the y-axis is the up and down
one and it looks like you've got a
really big difference but they've zoomed
in on a difference that isn't really a
difference to distort it
uh
people can say all kinds of things with
grass if they didn't label the axes if
they're not labeled with numbers or what
the
quantities are
you don't know anything
and my approach has been
to educate i'm
an educator to to try and educate people
about the different tricks and swindles
and really i think the most effective
thing to do is to start
with 12 year olds
i don't know that we're going to reach
people my age who have already made up
their minds maybe not even people your
age unless they're especially
open-minded but if we start with
12-year-olds in another 10 years we'll
have solved the problem
yeah and you know when one says that
there's a particular group that says
you're talking about indoctrination when
really you're talking about the opposite
you're talking about a toolbox for
people to think for themselves rather
than be indoctrinated into any
particular worldview is that correct
that's perfect i've never
sought to tell somebody what to think
just to teach them how to take a problem
apart and how to think about it and form
their own conclusions and if they come
up with a different conclusion than i do
that's that's what democracy's all about
i like you i embraced that discussion as
long as the process was reasonable
and and somebody wasn't tricking them
when it comes a little more specifically
to news consumption which you know we
can include radio television and online
kind of all platforms i'm going to use
an analogy to what many of us do when we
look at an article or hear a piece of
news for the first time one of the
difficulties it seems in self-driving
vehicles is that there are some
decisions that we as humans make
intuitively and quickly
that are really hard to have a computer
mirror a classic is do you go through
the yellow light or do you stop
and we're at the same time calculating
how fast are we going someone behind us
the width of the intersection all of
these different things and we're making
these decisions very very quickly in the
same way many of us myself included
similarly make decisions when we are
first presented with a news article that
we see somewhere
that's
fine i think to intuitively kind of have
that perception but there really is
a probably better sequence or toolbox
that we can have
to be able to assess for ourselves is a
piece of news or article trustworthy are
the assertions accurate what would such
a toolbox look like what would such a
process be for the average news consumer
well to begin with i think we can
recogni can recognize
although we don't all agree on this that
there are some people who are experts in
certain topics
so if you want to know about climate
change talk to somebody who works in the
field somebody who is a climate change
scientist
don't talk to a geneticist
or a biologist
a lot of the climate change
misinformation has come from people who
are not expert and for that matter if
you want to know about
something going on in the brain don't
talk to your foot doctor
i mean he or she might know but it's
less likely so
i think the average person doesn't
whoever that average person is don't
appreciate that there really are experts
who know things
virologists
uh is are an interesting case because
we've
during the pandemic
seen a lot of flip-flopping
and so people say oh well they don't
know anything or they're they're uh just
trying to make money off of us and the
reality is
the second part of this is to help
people understand how science works
because a lot of the information we
consume is scientific
science is a self-correcting process
they're flip-flopping
as they should when new information
comes in
they update their views
the third thing we can do i think is
understand that there's a hierarchy of
information sources none is perfect
none is unbiased all are biased and
imperfect
but what you want in an information
source is one that will
like science self-correct print a
retraction if it's wrong check its
sources before it goes with the the
article so
tmz is a sort of favorite case of mine
because they did break the story of
michael jackson's death before anyone
else
but they got lucky
for every story they wrote that was
right they wrote 20 stories that were
not right they've said that miley cyrus
was dead all kinds of stuff
and
so i tend to trust sources that are a
little bit more deliberate and
circumspect
and everybody has to draw the line
somewhere different but i think we all
agree there are sources that
uh are just kind of capricious they say
what they want and included in those
unfortunately
are
um
i guess they're not really
news shows they're commentary shows
people commenting on the news
which is not the news
right and that goes to media literacy in
in a sense i mean it's being able to
distinguish the difference between news
and opinions sometimes i'll get emails
praising me for being unbiased and i'll
say
i love that you love my show but i am
not a news show whose bias we really
should evaluate in those terms i mean
this is a program about my opinion the
problem is that there are media actors
that are deliberately blurring that line
oh for sure it leads to better ratings
if they say this is what's really going
on and let me tell you what they don't
want you to know
and i have unique access to facts that
you will never encounter
that always makes me a little suspicious
there's the you mentioned climate change
and a couple of other things which i
think lend themselves to to this next
sort of idea there's a contingent that
has
uh sort of um uh placed itself seemingly
above
the fray in terms of some of these
partisan disagreements by taking the
position that they are and this is my
it's sort of a pejorative an enlightened
centrist in a sense they've determined
here's what one side thinks and here's
what the other side thinks and i can
rise above this and find the truth and
it happens to be sort of somewhere in
the middle so if you watch fox news you
watch msnbc and the truth is between
those two and of course the problem with
this is with something like climate
science you know if you say well let's
bring in one person who says it's real
and one person who says it's not and the
truth is it's sort of like in the middle
this seems like a like a problem this
idea of the truth being in the middle
doesn't it
i agree uh there's not two look there
are two sides to many stories
uh but there are not two sides to a
story if one side is a lie
or a complete you know fabrication or a
distortion that that's not a side
and now that raises this thorny issue
well of who's going to decide
what's a lie and what's not and that
gets back to where we started i think
each of us needs to be armed
to make that decision for ourselves we
need a toolkit and i've you know i've
written a couple of books that provide
the toolkit but lots of people have i'm
not here to hawk my books there are a
lot of books on critical thinking
uh and
it's a muscle that you have to exercise
you don't learn it once
and then keep it because as you say it
goes against our evolutionary
bias which is to make snap decisions
rather than deliberate ones what my
teacher danny kahneman wrote about in
his book
thinking fast and slow
and so this enlightened centrist
you know one of them
you may know of is called allsides.com
yeah
where he presents four different views a
left to right
you know moderate left moderate right
and an extreme left or an extreme right
and then you can decide
um
the issue i have and i told him uh john
gable is that some of the stuff on both
sides is really not fact-based so it's
not helpful
and they need to do a better job of
sorting that out and again i come back
to well
as a rule of thumb
i would ask some experts and if the
experts disagree that's fine
i would report that
but there are some things that experts
really don't disagree about they
the suitable experts will tell you
that the measles that vaccine does not
cause autism right the information that
was based on was retracted
the guy was found to have fabricated
data
andrew wakefield he was his medical
license was taken away i mean that's
about as strong
a case as we have and yet people still
believe it because there are two sides
they think
you mentioned daniel kahneman who wrote
thinking fast and slow uh and much of
much of the book is based on the work he
did with with amos versky um one of the
things that daniel kahneman writes about
is that so much of our everyday lives is
based on certain cognitive biases and
heuristics that we many of us unless you
really take some time to learn about
them you don't understand them you know
availability bias you're very much
skewed to kind of what you see around
you as one example um uh
sometimes it's it's a bias to loss
aversion even when a loss and a gain can
sort of be the same thing mathematically
but depending on how it's presented it
feels different which of those biases
and heuristics do you think are most
relevant when it comes to news
consumption and what we believe or
disbelieve or how we evaluate news
you know i i worked in kahneman's lab as
a student and worked on some of the
experiments and uh kahneman
i'm sorry i worked in tversky's lab uh
and
kahneman was around a lot and uh tversky
and kahneman both said
that
this stuff is so hard you can teach it
to somebody and then they fall
again a month later and even phds and
statistics were failing
our little tests
fiendishly difficult
um
i think we have to face
the fact that we are all biased as you
have admirably done
we're biased towards i mean in a
trivial non-news way some people are
biased towards wanting to live in cities
some people like to live in the country
or in suburbs some people are want to
take a vacation to the beach some in the
mountains those are biases or
preferences but
hard to distinguish
when it comes to
what we can arm ourselves with
yeah
tversky and kahneman have this inventory
of like 50 different things
availability uh heuristic
representativeness heuristic the uh
belief perseverance
all these things
i don't know that we need to learn those
that's a lot of work yeah
i mean i find it entertaining too and i
would encourage anybody who wants to to
do so because it sharpens your mind
immeasurably
but from day to day
uh i don't you i don't stop and think
about that stuff unless it pokes me in
the face
it's such an obvious example of that
bias either in reporting or in my own
muddled thinking about something
what i really use is i look at the
headline and i ask myself if it's even
plausible
does it does it just pass
a simple plausibility test
uh and then i look at who's saying it
and where they got the information and
that that sorts through about eighty
percent of it for me
yeah and and it's admittedly a very
strange time because i think five years
ago
a headline like
the former president was flushing
documents down a toilet
we would all say it's not plausible and
and that would be the end but things do
change right i mean to some degree we
have to adjust to the current
circumstances
well that's a that's a wonderful point
there's this arcane thing we call
bayesian inferencing right which is just
a fancy name that statisticians and
doctors
and lawyers and judges use for if new
information comes in you put it on the
scale
so uh you know maybe the evidence for
climate change was that it was
um
just a natural occurrence maybe people
thought that 40 years ago and then
information comes in and at some point
the scales might be evenly balanced or
slightly tipped and the idea is
you have to stay open-minded you have to
be willing to learn something new that
may shake the very core
of what you believe
is there a single question that you
could leave us with that is the most
effective at starting conversations with
people in order to get them to have an
open mind
um
some some version of uh oh
i didn't know that or i didn't realize
that
where did you learn that or how did you
learn that right and then just follow
follow the question
and see where it goes and again
don't try to shame somebody uh
that doesn't work
don't try to
say that their view is ridiculous right
because they're going to shut down
emotionally and become defensive and
we've seen the research they'll double
down
but in our lab and in gordon pennycook's
lab in canada a simple question of
uh
do you think that's reliable
or where did you learn that or you know
a lot of people say unreliable things it
could
i don't know tell me could this be one
of them
yeah another one that i think is
interesting is
what would it mean for your world view
if this wasn't true
and you know with the trump was actually
the winner stuff there's a lot
emotionally wrapped up in the belief
that joe biden didn't really win and not
not everybody's willing to answer the
question but for a lot of these folks it
would be really
impactful
if their guy just genuinely lost rather
than there was this major multi-state
conspiracy to steal it and but but not
everybody's necessarily open to taking
that question seriously
well it's difficult david because in in
one version of this story what you have
to realize is oh
a whole bunch of people have been lying
to me right and i bought it am i that
vulnerable and that gullible right and
uh am i that defenseless uh
what we see with older adults who get
scammed
by con artists is they don't want to
tell anybody because they're embarrassed
right and they kind of don't want to
admit that it was their fault for not
asking the right questions they'll just
say oh well this person lied to me and i
you know
it's true some of those scammers are
very very good liars but uh in
government and media we have some very
very good liars too that's true that's
true
we've been speaking with daniel levitan
whose books include a field guide to
lies critical thinking with statistics
in the scientific method and also
weaponized lies how to think critically
in the post-truth era so appreciate your
time today thank you
thank you david this is fun